here's a peek at what guests had to say
after the show okay we are back on the
Internet Marc Maron how many cats is too
many cats you know they're asking that
beaut you have many Katherine yeah I got
a cattleman love me you love cats well I
love my cats I'm a my cat guy don't give
a [ __ ] about your cat but uh I don't
have maybe ninety in general in general
it's often lesbians who have many calves
well I mean what lesbian I'm not gonna
deny or confirm that but I am even a I
think you when you have too many cats is
when someone comes over to your house
and within three seconds goes Jesus did
a giant cat piss on your house I'm an
India I I have to one is uh oh come on
boy ones on hiatus or eaten by coyotes
it's not clear to me really it's
horrible it's all run away don't do well
I know he didn't run away he got taken I
think or else he's living with a kind
lady who's giving him nicer food and if
that's the case I'm glad he's still
alive and if I find that woman I'm
taking my [ __ ] cat packet um I have
two in the house there's a couple of
strays outside that I feed and some that
come and go it is it is a terrible
Hobson's choice isn't it because if you
keep the cats inside yeah that's a kind
of a cruel fate that's worse than Gitmo
no they like they're all right just to
be inside all that's no they get used to
it they like you he what he had to go
outside because he peed on everything
and it you know there's a tough choice
to make but one day you wake up and you
go holy [ __ ] on me he peed on me and
then you got to make a decision but I
mean I think they're happier when they
can roam around outside but it's more
dangerous it's like being single versus
being married yes when you're single
until you could always get eaten by wild
animals do you certainly can if you're
lucky
yes um okay at what age I guess this is
for everybody at what age would you be
comfortable with your child handling a
gun uh well we are childless yeah I am
you know I've been yeah three year old
Anna eight month old so neither of them
but I would say cool couple
let me start they're really going out on
a limb there alright
I mean you're gonna piss off the NRA if
they hear that I mean guns out of the
hands of three-year-olds are you sure if
you own a firearm you'd better make sure
your child knows how to handle it safely
safely or understands why it's dangerous
what age should you start them when
they're when they're able to understand
arm you should have it locked all right
with your child can't ever get at it
under any circumstance but what if
they're at a friend's house or something
like I mean you have to they should
understand and know let me hear that out
of hand when they're at a friend's house
well I don't know my your guns at home
and when they're at a friend's out of
their friends awesome whether or not a
gun there what if their friends parents
dunk yeah well here's what you do with
that you don't play with those kids with
the unlocked gun on the house you don't
know what you ask
guns unlock you don't always know I mean
you make a play date with Veronica are
you I have found that what it means in
Santa Monica before use their guns lying
around okay where's that mean you're
kidding Santa Monica but you think
that's something you should ask another
parent I like my little boys coming over
to play with yours do you have any guns
lying around if you if your guns not too
many yeah you better yeah variable
they'd probably that's it so what ya
know if you live in Cumberland County
Kentucky now that should be your first
question cuz that that's that's where
the five year old shot the two-year-old
right okay uh Maddie in your opinion
should girls have unrestricted access to
plan B that's the the birth control the
over-the-counter birth control right
Plan B isn't that what they call it the
isn't that ru-486 yes I am
or should there be an age limit well
this was in the news this week because
the FDA said no it should be available
for 15 and older without any sort of
parental permission we have our
president who is talking to Planned
Parenthood one day and then decides to
appeal a decision what the next device
and that either I mean that's a very
difficult situation for people who for
this for them is a voting issue for me
it's not so I don't really have an
opinion that really good I mean I'm not
a scientist I know that that's kind of
the Obama administration's um I think
that five-year-olds gonna have guns 15
year olds gonna have birth control your
guns in birth control I just I think
it's no but I don't the Obama
administration's position is that
there's scientific evidence for at what
age it makes sense to give unlimited
have not not have limit to this kind of
drug I'm not sure that I buy it but I'm
not sure that I really care either so
okay we should we should try to arm the
fetuses so that they can defend
themselves I mean let's keep going down
the line at least get them comfortable
with fire
make sure the defeatist is comfortable
with the shotgun heat aside from new
leadership at the VA what is the most
important step in creating an efficient
system for veterans to apply for
benefits no because that's been in the
news a lot well it has and our
organization was was the first to come
out and say that secretary Shinseki
should step down honorable man he's been
there for four and a half years really
hasn't gotten the job done you got it on
him
the bet well it's not just on him it's
on a calcified bureaucracy that treats
every vet like a number and tells you to
wait in line for two years if you live
in LA and we should do better than that
we can do better than that and you know
what there are a lot of private sector
companies that have figured these kind
of processes out a lot quicker so why
don't we learn something from them so we
can actually deliver services there's
money involved this is the United States
of money of course when money is
involved they can do it they can't count
the votes accurately either but banks
never make a mistake but there's very
little incentive somehow they never go
you know what it's about ten thousand
either way if it's if it's in your favor
we're good we don't care we don't you
know there's no incentive for the VA to
fix it I mean the backlogs up to hundred
percent while their funding keeps to go
out to two thousand percent over the
over the last four years the backlog for
VA but they're there their budget has
gone up 40% I mean that's an abject
failure
someone should be held for account for
it and
should create incentives for workers who
are good nature didn't want to do
goodbye that's to do even better because
we can so just so I get this straight I
did just hear you say there is a federal
budget item that should be increased
well not if it's going to continue fail
no but not okay I mean there's there's
ways if the money throw more money let's
leave it feeling the way it is no the
plan is not my point
then if we're not gonna continue to fail
let's spend it's a process problem not a
lot more money it's a prostitute right
I'm not asking for a dime more no you
just did no I'm not asking for your
money to roll back the tape no it's
processes it's accountability
I would like to roll back the tape I
don't you don't need a dime or something
honestly sometimes throwing more money
the problem doesn't fix it sometimes
that's been the problem that has it
there's lack of accountability awash in
money no does no reason or incentive to
change processes that if you you think
the VA is underfunded is that that I
don't know I don't I don't have a view
of this but it but you know if the back
wall and as a few of this absolutely she
doesn't care about heart disease I know
I think you don't care what happened to
your cat we go to overtime
thank you bugs what is it what their
funding levels should be but I will make
you this guarantee if you cut their
funding level your backlog is going to
go up even more well we're not talking
about cutting it but yes we are it's
called sequester nope well no VA has
been exempted from sequester horns
you've gotten all the money they need
they want you know I'm starting to feel
I don't know any - everything okay
Maddie would you have accepted me $10
with spending cuts for every dollar in
tax increases that Obama proposed that
was a big issue
no no so you would have been one of
those who raised his hand at the
Republican debates who said nope yes
because here's the problem with that
deal it doesn't actually exist this is
the unicorn that Democrats keep saying
is such a great deal why don't
Republicans just take it we've had two
examples of when this has actually been
tried and has failed both President
Reagan and the first President Bush made
these deals with Democrats they said I
will give you $1 in tax hikes for every
$2 in spending cuts or for our Reagan I
think it was $3 in spending cuts and
what happened was these tax hikes were
always real the spending restraint never
materializes because as long as you put
another dollar on the table the
government's going to
to spend it so you don't get any
restraint as long as they can continue
to get money it's the same thing that
we're just talking about the VA there's
no incentive to have any kind of change
in the status quo if you're going to
keep throwing money at it's the same
thing with these budget deal we have
time for the truth yes okay so here's
the thing forget these deals that you're
talking about let's talk about the deal
that the Democrats did with the
Democrats with not one Republican vote
1993 and it was one to one
it was a deficit reduction bill that was
the same amount of tax increase to the
same amount of spending cuts okay
one to one the tax increases went into
effect and all of the spending cuts went
into the effect most of them in Medicare
by the way the first thing Bill Clinton
and the only thing Bill Clinton did with
Medicare was cut it in his first year
and those were all real cuts and that is
how we got the deficit down with
additional cuts that Newt Gingrich
forced on Clinton years later got it
down to the point where we actually had
projected surpluses handed over to
george w bush which he threw away so
this is a lie that republicans will
never stop telling that we only do the
tax increases and we never do the budget
cuts and it's a lie about newt gingrich
who actually did do the budget cuts so
it does happen so but how much do we
know about these so-called facts it was
so-called Ryan very much we have to go
Real Time with Bill Maher Friday night
at 10:00
ask bill and his guests to her questions
right after the show at hbo.com